thomas soul uh
wrote a book about uh recent book
on um charter schools yeah i would like
to talk to him
yeah he's an interesting guy we will
disagree about a lot but respectfully
yeah such a powerful mind yeah uh but he
i i need to read i've only heard him
talk about the book
uh but he argues quite seemingly
effectively that
that um that the public education system
is broken
that we blame he basically says that we
kind of blame
uh like the conditions or the
the environment but uh the upbringing of
people
like parenting blah blah blah like the
uh the set of opportunities
but okay putting that aside it seems
like
charter schools no matter who it is
that attends them does much better than
in
in public schools and he puts a bunch of
data behind it
and in his usual way as you know
just is very eloquent in arguing his
points yep
so that to me just highlights man we
don't
education is like one of the most
important the it's probably the most
important thing
in our civilization and we're doing a
shitty job of it
in academia in uh uh in university
education and
you know younger education the whole
thing
the whole thing and yet um we value
um
just about anyone or anything more than
educators you know part of it is just
the
relatively low regard
that americans have for teachers for
teachers
so also similarly like um
just people people of service i think
great teachers
uh are the greatest
thing in our society and i would say now
in a controversial
note like black lives matter uh uh you
know great police officers
is the greatest thing in our society
also like all people that do service
we undervalue cops severe like this
whole defund
the police is missing the point and it's
a stupid word
i'm i'm with you on that left side our
um
neighbors to on one side of our house or
three generations of police
or neighbors across the street our
police
they know my
you know political predilections
and we've gotten along fine for
30 years and i go out and tell them
every day
you know when you go in today you tell
the people on the force
that i appreciate
what they're doing i i think it's
really important to not tribalize
those concerns
you